I'm Ed Graetrichs and I'm an assistant scoutmaster with Troops 63 in Monroe, Connecticut.
This edition of the Scoutmaster podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
Thanks everything you do, man.
And now to you, Scoutmaster.
I was enjoying my morning cup of coffee in the campsite
And one of my assistants, Scoutmaster, said to me.
he said: you know, I got up very early this morning and I saw a deer in my pajamas.
He said: how did a deer get in your pajamas?
Oh, it's an oldie, petty goodie.
This is podcast number 314..
Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast. This is Clark Green.
Let's take a look in the mailbag and see what's on offer.
Oh, we have this from Walter Underwood, who joined us in last week's podcast to review the troop leader guide, volume 1..
And Walter read and reviewed my book, The Scouting Journey, on Amazon.
He gave it a five-star review.
He said: I've made several attempts to read Baden Powell's AIDS to Scout Master's ship,
but I don't think I ever made it all the way through without losing the thread.
It's not a long book, but the 1920s language and ideas required a continual translation in my head.
Clark has set out to write the same kind of advice for today's Scouters with great success.
This is easy to read and a great introduction to what it means to be an adult leader in Scouting-
Highly recommended.
Thanks so much, Walter.
I really do appreciate that.
Once again, the book he's talking about is called The Scouting Journey
and it was my goal in that book to take all of the ideas from Baden Powell's AIDS to Scout Master's ship,
which is couched in language that a lot of people, including myself and apparently Walter,
find. you know. you've got to kind of wade through it.
It's a little bit of a slog
And what I wanted to do was to take those ideas and update them and make them more readable and accessible for people today,
And I think I was reasonably successful in doing that.
Check out The Scouting Journey.
It's on Amazon.
I'll have a link in the podcast notes.
Also heard from John Dyer about last week's podcast number 313..
He said an excellent review of the new guide.
I enjoyed listening to the two of you discussing the content.
Thank you, John, for that.
When I posted last week's podcast on Facebook there was a little discussion that started with somebody saying:
you know they never should have changed the name of this from the Scout Master Handbook
And it was a pretty weak excuse
And my opinion is just watering down scouting,
And you know I really take exception to that.
I don't think this is watering anything down.
I think it was expanding the idea that the information in this book is for all scouters involved with a scout troop
And it's very helpful for them to have it and to be able to reference it.
So calling it something other than the Scout Master Handbook was probably a very good idea
And a couple of people agreed with me on that.
And then, to be really argumentative, someone mentioned that it shouldn't really be called the troop leader handbook
because the only real leaders in a troop are the scouts,
And I agree in principle. but nobody asked me what this publication should be titled.
If they had asked, I would have agreed and said let's call it the troop scout or guidebook or something like that.
And you know it does do a very good job of explaining
Adults. are there not so much as directive, leaders, guides and mentors to the scouts?
I'm so happy with the content of the book,
I don't want a nitpick with the title,
Okay. so
Hey, we have a live chat session a couple times a week, usually Tuesday and Wednesday mornings.
Go to scoutmastercgcom and check in
And you can sign in during a live chat
And we discuss all kinds of important stuff and things that aren't at all important.
We usually have a number of frequent flyers join in
And also this week, welcome to William J Smith, who is the scoutmaster of troop 204 and carry North Carolina.
So Tuesday and Wednesday mornings, watch the Facebook feed and the Twitter feed
And come and join us at scoutmastercgcom for a live chat.
Before I get too much further, I want to ask you to do something for me.
Consider lending some financial support to helping me keep the podcast and the blog up and running.
There are some significant costs to doing it, including my own time that I put into it.
I've created two different ways that have been very successful to help lend financial support to my work.
One is to become a scoutmastercgcom backer.
If you go to scoutmastercgcom, look up at the top of the page, all the way over on the right hand side,
You'll see a support link that will guide you through the process of becoming a backer.
It only takes a couple of minutes.
Take a look at that this week and see if that'll work for you.
Also, right there next to it is a link to Patreon P-A-T-R-E-O-N where you can become a patron
Or basically a subscriber to scoutmastercgcom for a payment of $5 or more per month.
A number of people have chosen to help out in that way
This week. I want to take a moment to personally thank Timothy Cherry and Hoyt Condra,
who both became patrons since last week's podcast.
In this week's podcast we're going to catch up on email questions that have come in over the past several weeks
And I'm going to limit myself to answering four of them. otherwise we would be here for a while.
If you haven't heard your question answered on the podcast, try and answer them as soon as I possibly can by email.
But if you haven't heard yours on the podcast, that's because there's a bit of a backlog
And we're going to take care of four of those questions on this podcast. so let's get started, shall we?
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You were always on the beat Boy, beat Boy.
Yeah, you were always on the beat Boy, beat Boy.
I'm hanging in the street Boy, street Boy.
We were dancing to the beat Boy, beat Boy.
Yeah, you're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
You're my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
He's my favorite all-time Boy Scout.
Write me a letter, Send it by name.
Couple of the emails that we'll be talking about this week will remain anonymous
for reasons that will readily become apparent as soon as we delve into them,
and I'm perfectly happy to not mention anything about where emails have come from.
but I think it's particularly important, especially when we're dealing with sensitive or difficult questions,
to just be able to share the question without any personal information being shared,
because I think it helps everybody out.
So I had this email that begins. while I certainly enjoy the informative and entertaining nature of the Scout Master Podcast,
What keeps me coming back is your experience and ability to see through seemingly difficult situations with care and guidance.
One of our adult volunteers passed away suddenly,
and there really isn't a playbook for this.
What role do I have as a scouter?
What role does our troop have?
How can we help the Scout?
How can we help the family?
Well, as I read your email, I was reminded of an experience about a decade ago
when the father of two of my Scouts, two brothers, took his own life.
It was sudden, it was horrifying, and I had no idea what to do next.
I mean, what do I say to these two boys.
What do I say to the other Scouts?
I realized I was way out of my depth
and thankfully I had a connection to a professional counselor who I contacted
and she and a colleague offered to be at our next troop meeting
to talk with the Scouts about what had happened.
This counselor done a lot of work with youth
and I felt very comfortable in taking her up on that offer.
Now I had no idea of the kind of a meeting this would be,
how things would go, what would be said or how it would all end up,
and I guess I could credit myself for knowing I was out of my depth
and asking for help. but to be honest, I was horrified at the prospect
that I would do further damage if I took it on by myself.
The boys who lost their dad came to that meeting along with their uncle.
The counselors divided us into two groups and spent the rest of the time
facilitating a discussion with the Scouts.
I was not sure I had done the right thing at all
and I was hardly able to listen to the conversations, much less participate in them.
but when we dismissed the boys and uncle told me it was tremendously helpful
and it was a great relief to him personally
and we went on from there and I don't really recall any issues coming up after that session,
and I could write a lot about what I learned,
but the single takeaway from the experience was recognizing
that I was really out of my depth and asking for help,
and that's my best advice to you
or anyone who finds themselves in a similar circumstance:
get some professional help with this, if at all possible,
from people who are trained and experienced with helping children
process these kind of losses,
because, as you might imagine, the loss of a parent
is not simply upsetting to the children in that family,
but any children who those children may be associated with.
I know that it may be a little difficult for some of us to go.
you know I'm really way out of my depth here.
I really need to have help. I can't handle this,
but these are very serious issues
and I would liken it to this:
if one of your scouts was seriously injured,
you would know when you are out of your depth
as far as what you're able to do for that injury. right,
you're going to call the EMTs, you're going to get them to an emergency room,
and this is the same sort of a situation
you're out of your depth, you don't really know what to do next.
don't ever be afraid to ask for help in a situation like this.
I was fortunate that within the circle of my friends,
I knew somebody who was a professional counselor and could help out.
if I hadn't, I would have widened that circle
until I found somebody who was able to speak with me about it.
so that is what my advice would be:
when you're handling any kind of an issue
where you feel, as a scouter, that you're out of your depth,
don't be afraid to ask for help.
our second question for this podcast also remains anonymous,
and it begins this way:
I found out a couple days after a recent camp out
one of my older scouts was teaching younger scouts
some very profane, explicit limericks,
and I am really pretty upset about the whole thing.
I understand that we're not supposed to punish scouts,
but I really question the judgment of this older first class scout
who's ready to advance to STAR,
and I am suggesting that we delay his rank advancement for four months.
what advice do you have for me concerning the advancement issues specifically-
and I'm open to any other advice you might have about this-
well, I wish I could say that this never happened to me.
this sort of an issue is going to happen
when you are working with boys this age.
boys this age do this kind of thing.
this is not to have a. boys will be boys,
dismissing the behavior attitude towards it.
but we need to understand why they do this sort of thing.
this isn't some kind of basic moral failure on their part.
it made perfect sense for him to do this. okay,
I know that if I were this that age
and I knew some off-color jokes
or dirty limericks or something like that,
I would think that they were the best thing ever
and I would make sure to share them with my friends,
and especially with younger people,
because I would make this equation. they would think I was pretty cool.
so it's a win-win situation as far as I can see,
of course, unless somebody finds out that I was doing it.
but I'm not really worried about that at that age.
I mean, of course, this scout knows better.
he probably feels pretty bad about the whole thing
or at least embarrassed that somebody caught him,
because teenagers are very poor estimators of risk.
they tend to value the positive outcomes
of taking a risky action like this
way way above the negative outcomes.
that's why we have something like a juvenile justice system
and emergency rooms. okay,
teenagers make very poor decisions
when it comes to things like this,
and by doing that, this is a process
by which they learn to make better decisions.
just about every young person that we know,
including the ones that you're a parent to,
that live in your house,
no matter how great and wonderful a kid they are,
they sometimes just do a stupid, stupid thing.
that is just so jaw-droppingly stupid
it stops you in their tracks.
theoretically, of course, they know better,
but they don't experientially know better
until they push the limits a little bit,
and I think that's what's going on here.
I know it's what I would have done at that age.
so what do you do next?
well, if you come at this from the punishment direction,
this scout is going to do what we all did at that age.
he'll do a passable job of saying that he's sorry
and act repentant in front of adults,
and then he will likely kind of thumb his nose
behind your back,
because he knows that adults are somewhat hypocritical
in this area
and that adults know plenty of raunchy jokes
and swear once in a while,
and so there is an inherent unfairness that's going on here,
coming at them with a punishment
is going to backfire on you.
plus, we don't punish scouts.
we just don't do that,
and I've talked about this many, many times before.
punishment never happens in scouting,
should never, ever happen.
proportionate consequences happen.
if you make a mess,
you clean up the mess.
if you break something,
you fix something.
if you share an off-collar joke
with a bunch of younger scouts,
you apologize for having done so,
but you don't get punished
for any of those circumstances.
you just deal with the proportionate consequences.
anything above those proportionate consequences,
that's punishment.
Scouters don't punish.
parents can have the option to punish
if they think it's going to be useful for them
and that's the way they want to handle it.
so we make sure to let parents know what's happened
and it's their choice to punish
or not to punish.
the other thing that is really important here
is the kind of conversation that you can have with this scout.
if you just like, look at the situation
and you issue a judgment
and that judgment is followed up with some kind of punishment,
like making him wait an extra four months
before he can be a star scout.
you've missed a really big opportunity.
that four months is going to go by.
he's going to forget about that.
but if you have a really meaningful, open conversation
about the scout oath and law,
he'll probably remember that conversation
longer than he will remember that punishment.
so sit down with the scout
and start asking some questions.
why would anybody be upset
about what he did?
why have him explain that to you?
does he think that the scout
oath and law mean anything,
or are they just empty words that we repeat?
what would he do in response
to a situation like this
if he were in your shoes?
does he think what he did was wrong?
can he tell you why it was wrong?
does his conscience tell him
that he was acting in the best interest
of those younger scouts,
that he was demonstrating the kind of scout spirit
we'd expect of a star scout?
I mean, this is a very meaningful discussion here.
when you have the chance to get this scout
to exercise their own internal standard,
to explore the ideas behind the words
of the scout oath and law,
you won't be able to have that conversation
if you decide to pronounce judgment
and issue a punishment
as a part of the conversation.
you have to make it clear:
if this kind of thing becomes a pattern of behavior,
well, he won't be able to continue in scouts.
it's pretty simple,
and that you need to have a discussion
with his parents about the whole issue,
because it's your responsibility to his parents
to share this sort of thing with them
and they may choose to punish him
kind of out of your hands,
but that he needs to understand
why you have to talk to his parents about it
and you want them there
while you talk to the parents.
this will be as big an issue
as you decide to make out of it,
and I would make it
as small an issue as possible.
scouts are smart.
they understand when they've done things wrong.
we don't have to bludgeon them over the head about it
for days and days
or for four months.
let's talk about it honestly and openly,
use it as an opportunity
to leverage their growing,
their understanding of the scout oath and law,
make sure that any punishment
responsibilities are right where they belong-
with his parents, at home-
and move on
and put a positive spin on what is
honestly, yes,
very frustrating for a scouter
to have to deal with things like this,
but if we take it as an opportunity
to help a scout
form and shape their character
through the application of the scout oath and law,
it becomes a very positive thing.
so our third email this week
comes from Christopher Taylor.
he says: I'm a long time fan
and assistant scout master for a few years,
and I was looking for guidelines
on making a Facebook group
for our scout troop.
if I did create a Facebook group,
it would be private, of course,
with invite request admission only.
your thoughts would be appreciated.
well, Christopher,
I sent you to a link
from the Boy Scouts of America
and their official position
on the use of social media
and it will also be in the podcast notes
and you'll note on that page.
it says this:
to help ensure that all communications
on social media channels remain positive
and safe,
these channels must be public.
therefore, no private channels,
eg private Facebook groups
or invite only YouTube channels etc.
are acceptable in helping administer
the scouting program.
so that's the BSA position on the matter.
my personal advice to you,
after having tried out a number of these things,
is to just leave them alone
and don't get involved with
trying to set up a troop page
for your Facebook
or anything like that,
because they're not a very good way
to communicate with your Scouts
or their families.
I know it seems like a good idea,
but it's likely not to be,
because there's really no closed loop
communication involved
where a person at the other end of the communication
acknowledges that they've received it.
and when you set up a group like this,
whether it's private or public
or whatever,
it can take constant monitoring
and there are potential problems
with youth members and adults
friending each other on Facebook
and not being able to monitor
the resulting interactions
and the inevitable misunderstandings
that can arise from these kind of interactions
between youth members,
between adult members.
you get where I'm saying
now. I wrote about this
about three or four years ago.
I'll have a link to those articles
in the podcast notes.
but to give you the quick analysis,
while all of these social media tools
and things like that
do have their uses
and they are useful for some things in Scouting,
in my experience-
and other people may be able to do this successfully-
but in my experience
they don't work for unit communications
and they're really a pretty bad idea
because of the other potentials
that I just mentioned.
I go back far enough to remember pre-email days
and we tried lots of different things.
we tried paper newsletters
mailed out going home.
those helped a little bit.
we tried having a recorded phone message
where you could call up
and get a phone message about what was happening.
and then, of course, email came along
and we all thought, hallelujah,
all our communication problems are fixed.
that turned out to be the case, did it?
then Facebook and the other
social media things came along.
we thought, finally, we'll have something to fix this.
then things like Scoutbook come along
and everything. we think
now we don't have to worry about communications anymore.
well, none of these things are 100% solutions.
some of them may help,
but when you add up
the amount of time that you have to
maintain and monitor them,
here's what I believe you're going to end up finding out.
the world standard is one person
talking to another person,
that's it.
whether that's over a telephone
or face to face,
it really doesn't matter.
but the only way you actually
have a reliable communication with somebody
that I like to call a closed loop communication,
where they say: yes,
I have heard what you said
and I understand it,
is through that face to face
or voice to voice contact.
my advice:
if you really want to
up your communication with everybody
to make sure people are understanding things,
I would put all that energy
into making sure that everybody gets a phone call,
and even that is not 100%.
human beings is our greatest asset
and our biggest problem.
communication is always a challenge,
no matter where you are
or what you're doing.
if you're getting more than three people together
around a given goal
or something like that.
communication is always going to be a challenge,
and I am not suggesting
people haven't figured out a way
to use social media
more effectively than maybe I did,
but I still think everybody would have to agree
that there's only one gold standard:
face to face,
voice to voice-
and that's where I think
your effort is better spent.
and our fourth and final email
will be anonymous.
here's what it says.
I have a situation developing
over the past few months.
I'm hoping you can offer me
some sound advice.
I'm a scout master
and one of our newer parents
has become a problem.
they are very critical
of what my older scouts are doing.
they are stepping in constantly
with comments
that are basically undoing
what I'm trying to accomplish
as a scout master.
I'm looking for a second opinion
and any offer of advice
how to resolve this.
I want us to find a happy place
where we can all win.
well, I'm sorry to hear this is going on.
don't feel alone.
it happens all the time in scouting
and outside of scouting too.
every once in a while,
our scouts, our youth members,
may cause conflicts,
and these are usually
pretty easily resolved,
in comparison
to the kind of conflicts
and difficulties that adults create
distressingly, this is not
unusual or infrequent.
now, if you're a scouter,
and especially if you're a scout master,
that means you are a good-hearted person,
and this good-heartedness
serves you and your scouts
very well, until you have
a conflict like this,
because, being a good person,
you're probably averse to resolving conflicts
and you tend to avoid them.
and if you want to resolve this particular conflict,
I will tell you
in my experience,
the only way you're going to resolve it
is to take it head on
and make sure
that there is no further misunderstanding
about exactly what you need to have happen.
now. you've described an adult
who's clearly overstepping their bounds.
if they're a registered trained scouter
or just an active parent,
here's what I would do:
first discuss with your committee chair
what you're about to do
and then get this person
sit down with them
face to face
and you tell the adult something like this:
you are interfering with my work
as a scout master,
and your complaining
and your difficult attitude
is going to have to stop
as of now.
so here are my directions to you.
if you have a direction
or an observation
that you think needs to be shared
with the scouts,
you will come and talk to me. first,
to be clear,
I don't want you talking to the scouts
at all.
I only want you talking to me
when you bring these observations
or complaints
or whatever to me.
I will be happy to discuss any issue
or explain the actions that I'm taking
or how I'm going to handle it with you.
but we will be doing that
out of your shot with the scouts
when I have the time.
so let me go back over this real quick.
I don't want you speaking to the scouts,
I don't want you complaining to them,
I don't want you directing them
and I don't want you even sharing your observations with them.
now, that might seem a little extreme,
but your attitude
is causing difficulty.
so you and I will talk whenever you have a problem.
otherwise, I don't want you speaking with the scouts
unless I've specifically directed you to do so
now. if you don't want to follow this very simple direction,
then you'll no longer be able to participate
in meetings or on camping trips.
the way forward is up to you.
I think I've explained myself clearly
what's your choice
now. you have to be direct,
very, very clear about what you want to have happen
and you have to direct what's going on.
here's the very simple logic.
the scout master,
mentors and guides youth members
and leads adults.
I have no problem ordering adults around,
in a way that I would never order scouts around.
if you have an adult who has a problem,
you don't deal directly with it.
things will never be resolved.
part of your job is directing the adults
and you can't do this by being indirect-
okay-
or assuming that they understand what's going on.
you have to spell things out.
another way of putting it is: you're the head coach
and you can't have any assistant coaches
acting like they're free agents
who could say or do anything they like.
directions, comments,
anything that is communicating with the team
needs to come through you.
now. if this adult reacts poorly
or threatens to leave with his son,
then show them the door
and don't fret too much about it.
once in a while,
things like this happen in scout troops.
you're going to feel bad about it because you're a nice person,
but you cannot save a scout
from their own parents. bad attitude
or foolishness.
don't let it drag on.
don't think that suddenly this person with an attitude problem
is going to get the idea
and change without you saying anything.
this is something that you're going to need to address,
so I hope that helps
listen. if you have a comment, a question
or a reaction to anything we've shared on the podcast today,
get in touch with me.
it's pretty easy to do
and you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
thanks for listening to this 314th edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
keeping in touch is easy.
go to scoutmastercgcom.
there's 1,600 articles on the blog there.
there's a way to subscribe to receive updates by email.
there's a contact page there
where you can get in touch with me.
and, of course, you can get in touch with us
through the vast panorama of social media.
over 13,000 folks
follow the scoutmaster blog on facebook.
we've got a chorus of 1,500
tweeters. on twitter
we pin the poultry. there are
2,500 or so prolific
pinners who
peruse the poultry to news pictures
we proffer publicly. on Pinterest.
you can watch us at scoutmastercg
on youtube, but if you
can't face facebook and twitter makes you
better if you have no interest in Pinterest,
if you are not a person who puts the
you in youtube. that's alright,
don't worry about it. zoom into the late 90s
and fire off a good old fashioned email.
you can get in touch with me, Clark Green,
at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
that's C-L-A-R-K-E
at scoutmastercgcom.
and if all of those measures fail, you
write your message on a piece of paper,
hermetically, seal it in a container
such as a bottle and bury it
in any campfire circle.
I'll be sure to get it. I have agents everywhere
now listen. by this time, it should be
abundantly clear to you that the
scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not endorsed or sponsored
by any scouting organization,
nor is it the official publication
of anybody but me.
I have a microphone
and a way to get online. I know how to record a podcast.
who knew, huh?
I try to do my best to help my fellow
scouts and have a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, here he is
our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Kell.
Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping.
oh well, I thank you, sir.
until next time, everyone.
you.